parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
je t'écris ces quelques lignes pour te
dire que oui je suis prêt à faire un
petit bout de chemin avec toi ps quand
je parle de bout de chemin je veux dire
départ de chez moi arriver au boulot
puis retour mais aussi possible tous les
jours merci à toi le covoiturage c'est
convivial économique écologique avec le
covoiturage saint quentin en yvelines
vous propose une nouvelle façon de vous
déplacer les inscriptions et les infos
sur
www.covoiturage.fr lotir et est-ce qu y
point fr
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour une
nouvelle saison d' équilibre une toute
nouvelle formule désormais nous aurons
chaque mois des invités des portraits
des trucs et astuces et donc pour ce
premier numéro je vous propose de
découvrir les jardins familiaux de
trappes avec kaddour bouchareb bonjour
bonjour donc vous êtes le président de
cette association c'est ça voilà alors
de camp ça date un chat date depuis
l'année 2009 181 chèques exactement nous
disposons ici de 83 partiel donc chez
les 80 pas trois passes et alice ont
distribué à toutes les nations unies a
pas d'exception nous avons des noix de
la mauritanie nous avons des rues du
mali nous avons des turcs nous avons des
portugais nous avons des algériennes
nous avons des marocains ainsi que des
français s'est passé exactement
distribués aux gens ont retraité à
majorité retraités ce qu'ils sont mais
leur peine minime populaire pouvant les
aider admeta ou qu'ils puissent
admettant ce logiciel a besoin ainsi que
ce pigeon des familles c'est vraiment un
complément alimentaire pour les servir
voilà qui est un complément alimentaire
pour les familles ayant plus que ça
quand on a vraiment des familles ce qui
était employé ensuite quand on reçoit un
pour les riches et puis on a fait
quelque chose de shell pour parler les
emplois chez sai en plus que ça ça aide
beaucoup à la famille quoi est-ce que
c'est aussi vecteur de lien social est
ce que ça permet aux gens de se
rencontrer ce type jaoui ça c'est
l'essentiel ça c'est l'essentiel parce
qu'ils écoutent et parce que quand il ya
des gens quelles méthodes qu'ils
connaissaient même pas quand tu viens
ici dans le jardin ils sont triés ça
devient sa dynamique et
l'alliance sociale a créé une sacrée une
bonne ambiance et bien justement tout à
l'heure nous irons découvrir cette
ambiance des jardins familiaux nous
irons même à la rencontre du vétéran de
ses jardins en attendant je vous propose
de partir direction versailles pour
rencontrer alain baraton le jardinier en
chef du domaine du trianon et du grand
parc de versailles c'est parti
alors nous sommes à quelques 200 m du
petit trianon nous sommes dans des
serres d'apparence moderne mal
emplacement exact où étaient installés
les productions végétales de louis 15 il
s'est entouré d'une équipe incroyable de
botanistes de jardy et pas des moindres
il suffit d'ailleurs de cette et jussieu
pour en être convaincu
et si même il y avait des milliers de
plantes qui était rongé de manière
extrêmement organisés extrêmement
soignée du temps de louis 15 quantité de
végétaux nous sont encore inconnus
toutes les plantes qui viennent des
états unis avant qu'elle ne soit
installée passé par trianon pour être
mise en karaté en quarantaine elles
étaient étudiés observer et pourquoi pas
multiplier
les salles trianon sont bien sûr un lieu
de production végétale qui nous servent
vraiment à à planter dans les jardins
c'est aussi un lieu de présentation de
plantes pour intéresser les enfants à ce
que nous faisons nous produisons des
végétaux assez étonnant qui continue de
surprendre
ça c'est un mimosa c'est une plante
originaire des régions chaudes de
l'afrique et c'est une plante qui
fleurit également délicatement mais qui
a mis au point un système de défense
hors du plô m'a fait que les plantes
pour se protéger des agressions vont par
exemple se doter des pin et bien cette
plante a réussi un tour de force elle
est capable de bouger alors lorsqu une
vache arrive pour brouter cette plante
elle se replie instantanément et donne
l'aspect d'une plantes fanées et
l'herbivore n'a pas envie de manger
l'herbe sèche il préfère la laisser
tranquille
voilà elle va très bien qu'elle bouge
suffit d'ajouter un petit peu et
immédiatement eh bien elle prend
l'apparence d'une plantes fanées
c'est vrai
depuis que le château existe mes
prédécesseurs n'ont eu de cesse de
vouloir innover louis xiv en voile sur
les côtes méditerranéennes des galériens
piloté par le fameux arnoux à la
recherche de plantes rares que l'on
installera à l'orangerie du château je
pense aux lauriers roses ou aux agrumes
louis 15 introduit sur le sol de trélon
quantité de plantes qui viennent de
l'étranger je pense aux se fera du japon
je pense à quantité d'autres arbres et
puis je me suis rendu compte que mes
prestations à vue de cesse de vouloir
introduire à versailles des plantes
nouvelles et inconnues et aujourd'hui
souci ni storico oblige je fais
exactement le chemin à l'envers je ne
cherche pas à moi à introduire sur le
site des plantes inconnues des touristes
je souhaite retrouver les végétaux
plantés par mes prédécesseurs il ya deux
ou trois siècles et bien c'est tout
aussi difficile de revenir en arrière
que d'aller en avant parce que les
plantes ont subi tellement de
modification aujourd'hui pour nous
recréer des parterres tels qu'ils
étaient sous la royauté est un exercice
pas évident du tout
nous sommes toujours dans les jardins
familiaux de trappes et l'encours et je
suis avec louis gabriel bonjour bonjour
et donc vous êtes le vétéran de cet
espace de desjardins qu' on était quatre
compères créent l'association à l'époque
donc on a signé avec la l'établissement
public d'aménagement
c'était la zone là ici c'était une zone
comme qui descendait de la butte et tout
ça y'avait rien au début ça pour été
facile on la rue la confirmation d'un
établissement public qui nous fournirait
les abris de jardin et là je peux vous
dire qu'on a pleuré parce que il nous
leur fournissons les a montées le samedi
mais on n'avait pas le temps de laisser
les tout ça et il ya eu la tempête
c'était pour le noël avant noël à cette
époque là la tempe et toulouse avril il
était dans le fossé la mort
alors du coup là maintenant tout est
reconstruit d'ailleurs ça s'est vraiment
bien a grandi il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
beaux coups de terrain dont le vôtre
dont vos deux parcelles qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve dans vos deux parcelles bien il
ya un peu de tout devant moi là vous
avez des potirons derrière là vous avez
des fours des choses bougent là c'était
des choux pommes la voyage à tuer la des
épinards avec delà de la moche et ça ça
vous demande combien de temps de travail
par semaine or vous savez celui qui sait
bien l'emmener une heure par jour
une heure par jour ont fait du boulot et
c'est bien eh bien vous qui êtes
passionné 2 jardin louis je vous propose
maintenant de regarder un sujet qui se
passe au potager du roi à versailles et
oui retour à versailles c'est parti
à l'automne c'est le moment où l'on met
de côté tout ce qu'on a mis en culture
on va faire des récoltes les entreposer
pour en avoir tout l'hiver
c'est pas une année à fruits c'est
vraiment difficile alors pomme on a
encore quelques pommes ça va mais
pouvoir il ya pratiquement pas de
récolte on a eu trois épisodes de grêle
d'ailleurs ça ce soir là au niveau des
pommes là par exemple lesquels on peut
ramasser maintenant alors les pommes ah
bah ça dépend des variétés il ya des
périodes pour chaque variété puis ça
dépend du taux de sucre de la pop comme
ça ça soit pas forcément ici cd canada
gris et qui vont être à maturité on va
dire
voilà à fin septembre ça soit aussi au
niveau des pompes qui commencent à
tomber quand on a un taux de pommes qui
commencent à tomber sekkaki mois elle
arrive à maturité
quand on les récupère ses fruits on les
entreposent tous sont assez les uns sur
les autres ou alors que les ah non non
on les met dans des caisses justement en
plateau
pas forcément à touche touche et on les
met dans un local sombre et frais les
pommes mon frigo on peut les garder
quasiment jusqu'au mois de mars si on y
arrive à l'est avec le taux
d'hygrométrie et 6 degrés
on peut aller voir les courges
que ça c'est toujours sympathique
on
ici on a toutes sortes de courge donc
les courges défaut les récolter avant
les premiers gels puisque c'est une
plante quand même sensible et pareil on
va la stocker dont la stocke dans une
cave à l'abri de l'humidité et du froid
donc là il ya plusieurs variétés 1
voilà l'une
celle ci c'est marina di change ya
alors ça c'est les pâtissons orange
puis il y a les blancs
qui sont plus répandus
dire ceux là sont généralement utilisés
pour la décoration mais ça dans son
salon pour faire joli et quand on a
envie de les consommer bain dans les
cuisines si on veut les conserver comme
il faut il vaut mieux donc il ya le
petit pédoncule et puis généralement il
ya toujours 3 tiges et dont il suffit de
laisser 5 à 10 cm sur sa chaque tige et
la plante la course va mieux se garder
une paille à l'automne il va falloir
ramasser les tomates les dernières on
les ramasse même vert pour faire la
confiture ou pour laisser mûrir en cave
si on les laisse avec du papier journal
dans une caisse place tahrir même si
elles sont plus sur leurs pieds même si
elles sont plus sur leurs pieds alors
après il faut les prendre quand même
d'un diamètre assez gros c'est pas les
minuscules tomates vertes et ce qu'il
faut laisser son terrain d'une certaine
manière pour pouvoir replanter l'année
suivante ou est ce qu'il ya des choses
des consignes respectées question
complexe donc nous ce qu'on fait
évidemment on va arracher tout ce qui
est thomas tout ce qui est
qu'est-ce qu'on va arracher les
aubergines et poivrons toutes ces
légumes qui effectivement deviennent
tout tout tout sec est pas beau et puis
par contre ce qui est secours ge là on
va récolter nos fruits et là on va
passer le le broyeur pour broyer toutes
ces tiges de courges et on va laisser
sur place donc là ça nous fait un petit
couvert c'est aussi bien de laisser un
couvert sur la terre pendant l'hiver les
particuliers peuvent faire ça chez eux
ils peuvent faire ça avec des feuilles
avec de la tonte sécher son problème
m
ainsi s'achève notre découverte des
jardins familiaux et contrairement à ce
que vous avez pu voir il ne s'agit pas
de jardin exclusivement masculin il ya
également trois femmes qui font partie
de l'association merci beaucoup monsieur
de nous avoir accueillis aujourd'hui je
vous propose maintenant de découvrir
l'agenda du mois c'est parti et on
commence cet agenda avec une opération
nettoyons la nature à voisins le
bretonneux les sportifs et les amoureux
du vélo auront l'occasion de partir à
bicyclette avec l'association vélo ski
et surtout n'oubliez pas que le mois
prochain c'est la fête de la science
avec l'opération faites vos science est
un village des sciences qui s'installera
la maison de l'environnement voilà
équilibre c'est fini aujourd'hui pour
moi c'était la dernière merci de m'avoir
suivi mais ne vous inquiétez pas
l'émission continue un nouveau numéro le
mois prochain tchoubaïs